y una final que culminó con
enfrentamientos entre la policía y
adeptos ingleses tras las celebraciones
luego del triunfo del chelsea 10 contra
el manchester city recordemos que esto
también significó el regreso de los
fanáticos a los estadios de fútbol en
portugal algo que está totalmente
prohibido y que de hecho despertó duras
críticas por parte de políticos personal
de salud e incluso comentaristas que
aseguraron que la semana pasada cuando
fue la final de la taça de portugal no
se permitió el ingreso a los estadios de
público y en esta oportunidad sí para
extranjeros el gobierno había dicho que
los fanáticos tanto el chelsea como el
manchester irían del aeropuerto al
estadio del estado del aeropuerto algo
que no se cumplió de hecho hubo durante
dos noches consecutivas enfrentamientos
entre los seguidores de ambos equipos
las normas de seguridad para prevenir la
pandemia tampoco se cumplieron en su
totalidad aunque hubo mucha organización
al ingreso del estadio luego se podía
ver a los fanáticos sin mascarillas sin
guardar el distanciamiento físico
se tiene previsto que durante la
madrugada haya por lo menos 25 vuelos de
retorno a inglaterra para el a que para
que la mayoría de estos fanáticos
vuelvan a sus hogares sin embargo el
partido se celebró con total normalidad
bastante reñido entre ambos equipos y
resultando ganador el chelsea 1-0 contra
el manchester